hey guys and welcome back so this is
gonna be an unscripted video it's not
gonna be like my other ones so excuse me
if I stumble over my words a little bit
more than usual
so yeah Nintendo just dropped this new
trailer for Paper Mario the origami King
now if there's anything you need to know
about me is that Paper Mario the
thousand-year door is one of my favorite
games of all time even rivaling some of
the Zelda games not all of them but it's
definitely up there really also like the
first one Super Paper Mario also a great
game in my opinion even though it's a
little bit different it's not until
sticker star that they started to lose
me and of course Color Splash being very
derivative of that game also didn't
really do it for me I know there's
plenty of people who like it but it's
not for me I just want to go over some
of the stuff that we saw in the trailer
see what we can see in the first split
second I saw this door I was like ooh
that was in your door too but no it's
just a door inside of the castle as the
title suggests the main theme in this
game revolves around this origami paper
folding concept now this little guy
right here seems to be the origami King
which the game is named after which is
great because that means that Bowser is
not gonna be the main bad guy thank God
that stuff was getting old aesthetically
the characters have the same art style
as in Color Splash with this white
outline around it from what I can tell
this whole game is about characters
getting cursed into origami shapes I
guess because in this silhouette right
here we can clearly see like what seems
to be a koopa troopa being carried away
against his will probably to be
transformed which means that Princess
Peach has already been taken over as
soon as you've been taken over you will
fight on the side of the bad guy I found
this image on Twitter which solidifies
that the game is centered around this
regular characters versus the origami
characters we can also see that the
castle is slowly being taken over by
these swirls of paper so whoever this
little dude is he basically just barges
in and takes over the seat of power of
the Mushroom Kingdom that is pretty
badass there also seems to be some
secondary theme going on with this paper
mache stuff but I have no idea what
that's about now this right here is
obviously going to be the new companion
character whether or not this is going
to be the only
just like in color splash and sticker
star or if we're gonna see more
characters join the party that remains
to be seen
and you know right off the bat I can
already see that this game at least has
a more diverse set of characters which
is a good sign
at least it's not 95 percent totes like
in Color Splash I don't know if any of
the other characters that we see are
going to be potential companions or if
this is just a story segment or
something like that but it would be cool
to see Mario with a whole party of
colorful characters again we also get a
glimpse of one of Mario's new abilities
these large stretching arms which seems
to be used to peel off pieces of your
surroundings I don't know if there's
anything else that this can be utilized
for but it looks cool we see Bowser jr.
which well maybe he will be a companion
character that would be an interesting
twist similar to how Bowser joins your
party in Super Paper Mario I always like
it when a former bad guy joins you to
fight a common enemy in the beginning I
had no idea what this whole deal was
with Bowser like as a pizza box or
something like that but now that I think
about it perhaps Mario saved him before
he could be transformed completely and
now he's in this weirdly half folded
state which could explain why Bowser jr.
is friendly all of a sudden now this
section right here just looks amazing
having a vehicle and being able to drive
around a large open space in Paper Mario
count me in by the way I don't know if
you knew this but apparently toads were
already around in the time of the
ancient Egyptians we see like an aerial
bombardment or dog fight or something
like that
this is all-out war man there also seems
to be some sort of like world select
menu or something like with all these
pipes I really hope this isn't what I
think it is I know the world of Paper
Mario has always been sectioned off
before but at least you got to all these
places using different methods like by
boat by train by blimp through the
sewers which made it feel more like an
actual world but who knows maybe it's
just a minigame or something I don't
want to draw conclusions prematurely now
when it comes to battles what's this
they brought the audience back know for
those of you who didn't play Paper Mario
a thousand-year door the audience was
one of the most interesting aspects of
the battle system now I don't know if in
this game it's gonna work the same way
but in the thousand-year door it brought
something extra to the battles something
to keep your eye on the audience could
either help you out turn against you
fill your special meter stuff like that
now for all we know this could be pure
aesthetics but hey who knows maybe they
will bring the mechanic back in some way
we see Mario's HP up here but I don't
see any FP which was used for special
attacks in the older games but I'm
guessing that special moves might work
different in this game we already see an
indication of a new mechanic called ring
moves with a multiplier attached to it
apparently it has something to do with
lining up your enemies to gain stat
boosts which could be interesting but
wait what's this
no I really really hope that this is
just the name of the attack or something
like that
I mean Nintendo cannot be this stubborn
right the sticker and card mechanic is
probably the most complained about
aspect in sticker star and Color Splash
I mean what's the point of fighting if
you're just gonna waste your resources
and not getting any experience for it
now again I don't want to complain or
draw conclusions prematurely but as long
as I don't see a leveling system I'm
gonna remain a bit worried anyway I
think that wraps it up for now I just
wanted to give my two cents sorry if
some parts sounded a bit presumptuous or
negative but ever since Color Splash
I've been careful not to get my hopes up
too much I do have to say that this
trailer made a much better impression on
me then Color Splash ever did we already
see a much bigger variety in characters
bowser is not the main bad guy there's
some really cool cinematics going on
here there seem to be vehicles like cars
and boats that we can use to drive and
sail around so yeah it doesn't look bad
now let's hope they flesh out the world
with cool characters and cities and
stuff like that and have a battle system
that makes fighting enemies fun and
worth it anyway I've gone on long enough
this is dawn signing off and I'll see
you in the next video